друзі разом з колегами подали до
Верховної Ради законопроект Про
автоматичне надання статусу учасника
бойових дій сьогодні сотні тисяч людей
які заслуговують на цей статус не можуть
його отримати якісь просто кола пекла
проходять пишуть на їхні документи Не
можуть знайти вимагають якихось ще
додаткових згод і паперів безкінечних і
люди з окопів мають цим займатися ще
гірше навіть з госпіталів тож друзі це
треба владнати і влаштувати по-людськи а
саме щоб якщо людина приймала участь у
виконанні бойових завдань то автоматично
отримувала статус учасника бойових дій
відповідний законопроект ми подали
окремо всі ті хто знаходиться на
лікуванні по пораненню контузії травмі
пов'язаної з захистом батьківщини мають
також автоматично отримати статус у